now meanwhile public health england has
issued a statement
within the last hour saying that it does
not recommend
so-called mixing and matching of
vaccines it comes as the makers
of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine say
they are ready
to deliver two million doses of the jab
each week
by the middle of january that's despite
a warning from england's chief medical
officer
about shortages well today pfizer has
also said there is no supply issue with
their vaccine
but new government guidance suggests
that if supplies run low
vulnerable patients going for their
second dose could be given an injection
of a different type
to their first well the government's
green book on immunization against
infections disease
says for individuals who started the
schedule and who attend for vaccination
at a site where the same vaccine is not
available
or if the first product received is
unknown it is reasonable
to offer one dose of the locally
available product to complete the
schedule
this option is preferred if the
individual is likely to be
at immediate high risk or is considered
unlikely
to attend again well skies adele
robinson
joins me now uh it's all quite confusing
isn't it adele because you get the
pharmaceutical companies
saying you know there's plenty of this
there are no
capacity issues from our side and yet it
feels like our expectations
are being managed that we might reach
some pinch points with the availability
of the vaccine
yeah conflicting reports mixed messages
and overall a confusing picture is being
painted here of a seemingly
uh unclear strategy from the government
on this and now this
latest news that the uk government
appears to have quietly
updated its green book on vaccinations
saying that potentially vaccines can be
mixed as you say so that anyone who is
going for
the second dose if that dose is not
available
the same as the first dose that they had
or their first dose
it's not known exactly what they had
then they will be able to mix
they'll be able to have a different
vaccine as their second dose now this
flies in the face of guidance
given in other countries such as the us
which states that the
vaccines the different vaccines are not
interchangeable
and they're stating reasons of safety
and efficacy because they simply have
not yet been
evaluated there's even a quote in the
new york times from
a world-leading expert expert in
vaccines john moore
from cornell university who describes
this
from the uk government is seemingly to
have abandoned science completely he
says that
it seems like they're trying to guess
their way out of a mess in his words
and of course again it raises questions
over the decision to postpone
second doses for those who've already
had one dose
their first dose of the fisa vaccination
the government stating that they want to
maximize
as many people as possible getting one
dose of a vaccine
to give some level of protection and we
have this statement as you say from
public health england released within
the last hour
which basically the beginning of it
starts to say that it does not recommend
that vaccines are interchangeable but at
the end it sort of paves the way for it
this is what it says
we do not recommend mixing the covid19
vaccines
if your first dose is the pfizer vaccine
you should not be given the astrazeneca
vaccine for your second dose and
vice versa this is where it changes a
little there may be extremely rare
occasions where the same vaccine
is not available or where it is not
known what the patient received
every effort should be made to give them
the same vaccine but
where this is not available it is better
to give a second dose
of another vaccine than not at all so it
does appear to be paving the way
in some circumstances for vaccines to be
mixed and matched if you like and on top
of that we have that confusing picture
as you mentioned
on the one hand the government is saying
that there could be a vaccine shortage
on the other
we have the drug companies saying that
that's simply not the case so whether or
not it's a vaccine supply issue whether
or not
there are also other reasons such as a
workforce capacity or a mixture
of both of them it's still unclear
there's also some suggestion that red
tape is getting in the way of volunteers
coming forward to administer the vaccine
and all of this lumped in one is leading
to more and more criticism of the
government
for failing as it appears to be
according to those who are criticizing
them
to implement a proper vaccine roll out
strategy